successful track athlete full-time
olympic champion samoa farah joins me
now
it's good to see you this morning look i
know you're
gearing up for saturday when you're
doing your first 10 000
race for for what very nearly four years
is that nerve-wracking is that
nerve-racking
yeah it's quite nerve-wracking but
something i've really enjoyed over the
years and having tried the marathon and
and coming back i guess one last time
give it a go and uh
i guess i'm hoping it ain't gonna be
easy but defend my title and see if i
can make my country proud one more time
i mean it would be quite i mean i
thought i'm no athlete
but it'd be you know be quite something
if you'd if you didn't get picked for
the olympics wouldn't it
um no dude there's a lot of youngsters
coming through there there is there's a
lot of in terms of fifteen hundred
minutes eight hundred meters
there's a lot of youngsters who's three
or four or even five people got
qualifying time so
i think in generation it is changing and
i am
my aim particularly if i can see my
fellow athletes or younger athletes
coming along
and fill in that position what i did for
many many years
it's just nice to see but at the same
time even myself i'm not finished yet i
want to give it
one more go and see what i can do and
hopefully can
you know go out there and all you can do
is do your best
i mean in terms of the training you've
been doing ahead of saturday i mean
do you find yourself sort of getting
back into into the right pace for 10
000. yeah i'm getting that me and gary
locke my coach we've been working hard
for the last three years
together and things are moving forward
and i think the most important thing in
general is
somebody to understand you and and see
what works for you and what you've done
in the past and
i guess i haven't been too bad over the
marathon because i end up still running
british record european record
and then recently last year obviously
due to covet there wasn't many races at
all and i did that um
one hour on the track on the race and
broke the world record so i think i'm
still
there but i do need to sharpen up and
obviously
as you said it's a month and a half away
and next month and a half is the key
in terms of just staying on top of it
make sure don't get any injuries and
also stay on top of my dental care and
and make sure you know everything
is you know on fine tune
yeah yeah i mean in terms of discipline
between switching between 10 000
and marathon and back again i mean is it
is it quite a different discipline
yeah it's it's diff it's yeah i would
say it's definitely different and
difficult in a way
because often you know as an athlete you
see you're obviously watching me over
the years and even myself i went from
three thousand five thousand
ten thousand and then from now you last
like track events and then when you go
to the marathon it's 26.2
miles on the road which is much longer
so you'll be able to you have to be able
to stay in there for longer if that
makes sense and
still kind of run decent time still run
fast time so it is different
and now i've actually come back to more
of a
faster staff speed staff more so we can
fit in with this track
the 10 000. well look i mean i i know
you want to get to tokyo i know you want
to defend
that that title but are you concerned
because of the whole pandemic situation
i mean and what's happening in tokyo i
mean that
the figures there are pretty good but
obviously the vaccination figures
are very low and there just seems to be
some concern
yeah definitely there's a lot of
athletes who are concerned uh
obviously we'll go to the olympics games
and as an athlete ourselves
you know it is a once in a lifetime i
was lucky enough to be able to get the
experience from
london 2012 rio so i've got that but
that athlete's always thinking and i
think sometimes
in life if we overthink and make it
harder it comes more hard and it weighs
on you
other but at the same time i think we
can only do our best and
and keep training keep focusing and i
guess even myself
there's not a lot of races out there so
we're lucky enough you know having races
out there now and for me i'm definitely
seen in a positive way if we can see the
champions league final
so many people out there and and having
football back again
it just shows we're getting now
obviously it's not going to show
straight away but
we are taking forward step towards it i
mean you're looking at if you if you
qualify and you know
all fingers crossed for you of course
but you know you are looking at
at performing it with with only locals
in this in the stadia with no cheering
um i mean it's going to be very little
atmosphere is it is
i mean is that going to be difficult or
will will perfect professional athletes
just say
do you know what we're just going to get
on with it
now as a perfect athlete you have to go
on with it obviously we'd love to have
like as i said like i've been away for
a little while and it would be nice to
have my family my kids watching me on
the other side
and cheering for you and have a lot of
people but that is the situation we just
have to make the best of it
in terms of just no point us thinking
about it we would love to have it
obviously like
for me the memory i have london 2012
that memory always drives me to the line
and i just have to envision that and
and think like that but at the same time
i'm in good condition i've got myself in
great shape so
just do what i can yeah i mean you said
before about getting into good shape
you you referred to your teeth i mean
how important is it
i mean we don't think about dental
health with athletes but i know you
you were you were way laid by an abscess
back in
when was it 2014 or so i mean how
important is
how important is dental health
now dental care is really important to
look after yourself
and even myself i was part of it in
terms of 2014 where you know how to
absent in my teeth and got infected
um end up getting airlifted to the
hospital so
the whole point of all will be getting
behind was in terms of how do we prevent
that
and help the like myself professional
athletes
and the people out there to just kind of
are we aware of
do we know we're doing that we can do a
little better and that's that message to
it
yeah yeah look it's one professional
sports person can i ask you to reflect
on another and yeah you'll have seen all
the headlines about uh
naomi osaka you know she's she doesn't
like to do the news conferences she
she says she feels exposed and
vulnerable
in front of the media and
has it effectively had to pull out of
the french open at roland garros as a
result of that
do you sympathize with it do you think
we need to change our approach to how we
we treat professionals who may not be
comfortable in front of the camera
yeah i think it's definitely it's it's a
difficult one because like myself
often you know you you meet a lot
different athletes and yeah we're good
at what we do
and we it might not show and the time
when obviously our duties you know
to to give back to public and the public
have the right to be able to watch you
and do stuff but if it affects their
mental health and affect them then well
i think we should definitely
try and help in this situation and i
definitely
like myself i've been in that scenario
where you have
40 journalists uh you've got the camera
right in front of you
and it it's a nerve-wracking and um we
could only support
her but at the same time i don't know
what's going on in our normal life and i
think the most important thing to
make are they are they okay yeah we are
great sportsmen we can you know
do well what we do but mentally
physically is that person okay and i
think
i definitely have some um support for
her for sure because i'm
in that situation i'm sure it's not an
easy thing